if i have a runny nose or pain in my  elbow  or you know my hair starts falling out  my reflexive response  is curiosity it's not fear and that  fix it dominate it make it go away you  know sort of energy that we've been  uh reflexively conditioned around my  first response in so many  is what is this about interesting  right there's something that i'm  supposed to get from this  you know either i'm supposed to end my  relationship  or i'm supposed to change my breakfast  or maybe i'm supposed to look into that  smoke stack down the street  you know or that 5g tower or whatever  and there's something here that my body  is telling me is out of alignment the  body  wants to heal